let's go next to our caller from the
nine-oh-nine area code who is calling
today from nine zero nine David yes
hello
hi okay I have I have a question it's a
little bit different other but um I I
would really appreciate this information
my mate than that hold on a second
you're already you say your question is
or your name is there was just the phone
it just dropped and we missed up what
sounded like a key word there okay can
you hear me now yes okay my name is Ruth
Reardon love it Ruth and and my question
concerns voter tampering at the polls
because I feel like the polls are
already rigged in Donald Trump's favor
and I feel like he knows this and that's
one of the reasons why he just kind of
does whatever he wants to do because
what's the difference he's going to win
anyway and my question to you is this
okay based on that that premise which I
believe is a fact what can we do you
know the voters like what can I do to
put a stop to this or to bring awareness
to this because what's the point of
going down these rabbit holes debating
if Donald Trump is gonna win anyway
because the polls are already read so
here's my thought on this and I've been
thinking about a lot about this for the
last six months or so really really
longer let's not even get into debating
in what way the polls are rigged or if
they're rigged like let's just concede
that to some degree there is going to be
a combination of voter suppression and
messing with them I mean even concede
messing with some voting machines like
let's say there's going to be some of
that there are two things that we can do
before the election what we can do is be
activists any time that there is an
opportunity to push back against a voter
suppression technique to push back
against you know what's going on in
terms of irregularities with voting
machines in some places the voting
machines being used or being childlike
let's do everything we can in advance
but on Election Day
our turnout needs to so overwhelm all of
the foul play that the foul play won't
make a difference and in the end if
there's less foul play than what we
imagine there might be we just win by
more but the foul play only works to
some degree it works in states where
it's closed it works on the margins and
they know that so they also need to
depress the vote if we really get the
vote out we overwhelm those tactics
that's the reality so we've just we've
all got to go vote oh my gosh I feel so
much better hearing that thank you
right there's every every every time
it's the same thing Ruth where it's like
this time we're really Millennials are
going to vote and this and then it
doesn't happen right so we really need
to overwhelm the vote that's the thing
so the numbers from earlier this week in
Mississippi were turnouts up 70% but
Republican turnouts down 6% that's good
that's what we need in 2020 but it's not
a it's not a foregone conclusion okay
and you're served that what they have
done with the the polling equipment I
hear that I guess the Republicans are
the ones who fund it you're pretty sure
that that's not gonna just change your
vote automatically to trump if you vote
for his opponent I'm worried about let's
just speed that that's going to happen a
little bit they can't give them
California with that technique right I
mean like so this is what I'm saying
that stuff well you can do it
at the precinct level in states that are
going to be close so we've got to
counter it let's assume it's going to
happen and we've got to counter it with
overwhelming turnout
well okay then let's get out the vote
that's right okay Ruth the pleasure
you're getting I appreciate the call yes
of course thank you so much feel free to
call in again great to hear from Ruth
Ruth bringing some energy